Why don't the feminist complain about
Saudi Arabia?
It's like,
you know,
Gad Saad,
who's this guy at Concordia who is in a
business school so he can actually say
what he thinks now and then he tweeted
yesterday,
well he tweeted to the woman's march,
you know,
because there's little twitter thing you
could do that I suppose for the
organizers.
And he said,
why don't you go to the Middle East and
have a nice march again,
Saudi Arabia and see,
see how that works out for ya?
Like,
so you think,
well why not?
Like,
why not?
Why?
Why are the why or the radical leftists
who are so much for rights everywhere.
That's what they say.
Why aren't they complaining about Saudi
Arabia,
for example,
which you know,
breeds a particularly pathological form
of ideologically rigid his lap basically
in slaves.
They're women.
That's to put it properly.
It's like,
why not complaining about that?
Well,
how about this?
The enemy of my enemy is my friend.
And so when push comes to shove,
you see how much concern there is among
the radical feminists for the rights of
women.
It's like if,
if the pushing those rights forward
doesn't also at the same time under a
undermine the western patriarchy,
then we'll take the undermining and
leave the damn rights behind,
and so there's an insight for you about
exactly what's going on at the bottom of
all this.